great everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel right now I'm in Las Vegas
and I'm about to do zero gravity I'm
going to go play one two switch in
zero-g
it's super early in the morning they
wanted us to like wake up early to be
ready to go do this and I have
absolutely no idea what to expect
Vegas is such a weird place to walk
around at like 7:30 a.m. because they're
just so few people the lighting looks
exactly the same all times a day even at
midnight looks exactly the same indoors
but uh it's just way less people around
and I feel like a zombie outbreak is
like perfect timing I'm ready to go so
I'm just going to get a coffee right now
before we head to 0g for our briefing to
get our flight suits I'm incredibly
nervous
because this is one of the most extreme
things I've ever done but also really
excited
[Music]
so I now have my suit on which includes
an upside-down nametag apparently pilots
are only allowed to turn the nametag
around when they've completed the
post-flight so we'll get to do that off
Luis it's a pretty comfortable very well
so we do three separate kinds of gravity
in flight and it is just like a regular
domestic claim that they've modified to
make capable clergy so we do 1 Martian
gravity to Luna and then we go zero-g
for like 15 intervals of 30 seconds and
I think the idea is that kind of ease
you into it because they want your body
to get used to it so there's no inertia
or anything like that and the biggest
thing they keep telling us is John
pushed too hard because if you like jump
off the floor you would have straight up
going and feeling super quickly so it's
supposed to be like you just one toe to
push off not your entire force
[Music]
[Music]
holy crap you guys a full video will be
up on IGN actually has us playing the
switch it was a messy disaster but it
was so much fun I'll leave a link below
so you guys can see that but weirdly
enough the parabolic flight got delayed
it's a flight from Las Vegas to Las
Vegas but it still uses shared airspace
so it can still be delayed by other
flights that are actually going places
so because that often the flight
happened we had this [ __ ] insane rush
to get to Vegas Airport fly back to San
Francisco because out day was really
tightly packed I got back last night
dyed my hair which I'm aware completely
ruins the continuity of this video and
seriously I just can't believe that we
got to do that that is one of the best
things I've ever done one of the best
days of my life I couldn't really talk
while I was in zero-g because the plane
was so loud that I would have to yell
but I could not subtitling every second
of that I had a smile on my face and I
hate that I've already forgotten what it
felt like to be weightless because
that's what it is it's not literally
scientifically zero gravity the gravity
still exists you're just falling at the
same rate that the aircraft that you're
in is falling so it does give you a
sense of weightlessness but obviously
gravity still exists but it's just crazy
as soon as it kicks in you just feel it
you could not move at all and you would
just feel like you don't want anything
so huge thanks IGN for that opportunity
it was crazy awesome and thank you to
the zero-g team for being so
accommodating it was an amazing
experience
alrighty thank you guys for watching I
will see y'all next time